[Music]
i try to say about myself
[Music]
tom just let me do that oh no i gotta
kill tom
oh god i'm gonna go go go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i know you'll be heading for that door
not that i know where the door is oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh beyonce
yes you think you can
save him no no how did you do that
wait is braden god no no
no in that case oh no
no i'm taking him hostage
think ah
[Music]
she is a killer queen
i was
i thought
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
i can't see anything i can just where i
can hear something moving down here
it's flashing oh my [ __ ] yes
i'm actually getting wrecked
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't wait forever i'm not that
patient i got
too many things
and i know you find it hard when you're
[Music]
and i know you feel alone
inside your
[Music]
hi we have a mr
tetsubin
did you just call me i was not ready for
that
[Music]
we all scraped together this card
i hope you like it and look at it it's
you guys scraping your bums on the floor
[Music]
oh my gosh you guys
we can use it for animal crossing guys
thank you so much honestly it means so
this is
the island uh god and we need to
give him sacrifices to keep the god
happy
oh thank god and you give you this
you give it to the turtle or the
tortoise staffing turtle
and you do the gong you wake him up and
uh he decides whether he likes your
offering or not
if he doesn't like it then you might get
eaten but you know
[Music]
[Music]
i'm too emotional for this
[Music]
just give me five minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you